To avoid placing too much load on your scanning machines, you can limit the maximum number
of concurrent scans that they can run.
For newly added scanning machines, the default scan limit is 1.
If the scanning machine has enough RAM and CPU cores, you can increase the scan limit.
For more information, refer to our system requirements.
If you decide to change the scan limit, increase the number slowly and monitor the effect that
this has on performance.
To assign scan limits, perform the following steps.
From the settings menu, select scanning machines.
To change the concurrent scan limit, click the plus or minus icons.
Notice that license info shows you the total number of concurrent scans that you can run
across all of your machines.
It also shows you the remaining number of concurrent scans that you are licensed to run.
You can purchase a license for more concurrent scans at any time by logging onto your account
page on our website, portswigger.net.
You can purchase a license for more concurrent scans that you can use to run.
You can use a license for more concurrent scans that you can use to run.